[APPLAUSE]
JOE CONWAY: I hope you clap
like that after the talk.
I'm also very glad that
we had a lunch break.
Because following
some of the stuff
these guys had in the morning,
that would be a tough task.
So let's thank them
for all the hard work
that they do to
allow us to build--
[APPLAUSE]
--really great tools on
top of what they produce.
So my name is Joe Conway.
I am the CEO of Stable Kernel,
and we are a mobile development
consultancy.
And we have to write back-ends
an awful lot of the time.
And we started using Dart to
build our server-side stuff
about a year ago.
And as a programmer, the
most important thing is,
I don't want to
write a lot of code.
Because I'm human,
and I make mistakes.
And the more code I write, the
more opportunity for mistakes.
So as we were building
things, we were abstracting it
into another layer, a lower
layer that we call Aqueduct--
or "Ah-queduct."
I actually do not know
how to pronounce it.
And just to clarify-- so
what I mean when I say--
it's an open-source server-side
framework written in Dart.
And to clarify what
I mean by that,
just in case there's
any confusion--
you've got a getup where
you've got some clients,
and they're talking
over HTTP, probably
with JSON, or some sort
of format like that.
And they're hitting an API.
And then maybe that talks to
a database or another larger
system.
And that's where Aqueduct
goes, so pretty normal stuff.
One of the things we
want to do, because we
have to start from scratch
on all the projects
that we work for, is we want
to be able to get moving very,
very quickly.
And so the setup process
is extremely quick,
and there's templates
to get started.
And all you have to do is you
set up your packet, or pub,
to activate Aqueduct globally.
You run the setup one time.
I'll leave that surprise for
what happens when you actually
run it yourself.
You create a new project, and
then you're ready to go, right?
And the things that come
in the template here--
it's kind of a fully-featured
web application.
It's kind of ready to
start and get you going.
And you can build on top of it.
And so this magically
just fit on this slide.
But you get authentication.
So there's an OAuth
2 implementation
that's available.
You get a few routes
hooked up to ensure
that you can do authentication.
You get a registration endpoint.
You get scripts for
running your application
on EC2 and on Heroku.
You get the ability to reflect
in your code with a one-liner
and generate an open API
specification of the API
that you've built.
You can have a test harness.
You get stuff for testing.
You get configuration files.
You can put it onto Travis.
We've just kind of given you
all the things so that you just
say, OK, I'm going
to write some code.
So if you're going
to write that code,
you need to understand
how it works.
And it's pretty simple.
There's nothing really
revolutionary about this.
A lot of frameworks that
do this do this same thing.
You have this concept
of request controllers,
and they form a stream.
And when an HTTP request
comes into the system,
it starts with something
called a requestSync.
And that requestSync
forwards it onto a router.
And that router
forwards it onto,
based on the path,
different HTTP controllers,
or different types
of things that are
going to handle that request.
And along the way, something
might respond to the request.
Or it might forward it onto
a subsequent controller
to handle that request.
So for example, once that
request gets to a router,
and there's no registered
route for the path of the HTTP
request, it'll
respond with a 404.
If it matches one, it
passes it onto the next guy.
And that one's responsible
for responding to it.
Make sense?
Pretty standard stuff?
And so that requestSync,
that thing that's
sort of the initial
part of the chain, when
you create an
Aqueduct application,
you subclass requestSync.
And this is where you
set up your application.
This is where you're going
to set up your routing.
You're going to set
up any resources
that you're going to use,
like a database connection.
And the routing is, again,
pretty simple stuff.
This is an example of
a route specification.
And you're probably familiar
with syntax like this,
or this specific one,
where I'm saying, hey,
this route will go to /articles.
And then I've got these brackets
here, which means optional.
So /articles slash some index.
The colon here means a
variable, a path variable.
So this particular route
says if you send a request,
it has /articles, or
/articles/whatever.
Then we're going to move onto
something called an article
controller.
That will be the thing that's
responsible for responding
to the request.
The typical situation--
there's a lot of different ways
to actually handle requests.
The middle ground is
an HTTP controller.
So it's got a lot of power but
still retains some flexibility.
There's things that
go in both directions.
Like I can use a closure
here in this spot.
And I can just have
that respond to it.
But HTTP controller is
one of those things that
gives us a lot of value
and allows us to properly
compartmentalize our code.
So when you get into
an HTTP controller,
you've already been matched on
the route that you care about.
So we're coming into here.
We have /articles or
/articles/something.
And what an HTTP controller
does is it picks out a method.
It's a Dart method.
We call it a responder method.
And responder methods are always
decorated with an HTTP method.
So this is a GET.
So if I GET into this
controller with a request,
and it's a GET request, this
method's going to be invoked.
The responsibility of a method
like this is that number one,
it has to be asynchronous,
because you're probably
going to do some stuff in it.
And then it has to
return a response object.
And there's constructors for
all the different responses
that you need.
Response objects know how to
serialize and encode data.
So this will take these articles
that we get from somewhere,
and it will serialize this and
encode it into JSON by default.
And you can add
different encoders.
You can add different decoders.
But this is the basic format
of an HTTP controller.
I mark it up.
It calls a method,
responds to a request.
Of course, in this
particular endpoint,
we could get
/article/article/index.
And so if we wanted to
run a different method
for the particular case when
the endpoint is /article/index,
we add it as a parameter to a
different HTTP GET responder
method.
And so we're basically
saying here, in the route,
we've called this thing index.
We call this a path
variable in index.
And we specify the type.
And we're going to GET whatever
that path variable is parsed
into this particular type.
So the two different endpoints
for that particular route
are going to call one
of these two methods.
And this particular method
would go get a specific article
and return a different response.
So the great part about this
is, let's say, for example,
you passed in something
that could not
be parsed into an integer.
It would select this method,
try and parse that path variable
into an integer, fail, come
back and return you a 404.
And it will not
call your method.
Now obviously, once
you're handling a request,
you can always access the
Dart standard library request
object.
So here's some
code that you might
write to go in and grab query
parameters from the URI,
to grab headers.
We want to make sure
that they actually
include this particular header.
And so if they don't,
we return a bad request.
But that's boilerplate.
And the idea is to write less
code, because more code means
more errors.
And so HTTP controller
also has a built-in ability
to handle that type of thing.
So I can say, listen,
this particular method
is going to have a header
with X-Required-ID.
And it's going to have a
query parameter, potentially
contains.
And for you Dart
programmers, everyone here,
you know that the squigglies
here, that means optional.
And so that actually
means the same thing
for this particular
request handler.
I can get this method invoked
when I send an HTTP request,
and it could potentially have
a contains query parameter.
If it doesn't, I get null
for the contains variable.
And if I do, I get
whatever value they pass.
But this header here, this is in
the positional arguments, which
means that it is required.
And so if you get
to the point where
this method has been
selected, and you did not
attach X-Required-ID,
you're going to get a 400.
It's going to say,
hey, by the way,
you're missing X-Required-ID
as a parameter, as a header.
So again, it's just
making the things
that we have to do over and
over again a lot more simple.
Now because of
the way this thing
is structured, this idea of
having request controllers that
either pass it on or return some
response and do not pass it on,
we can add middleware
into the whole thing.
And so one of the examples
that comes built-in
is an OAuth 2 implementation.
And within the OAuth
2 implementation,
there is a request
controller called Authorizer.
And we can just put that
in between the router
and a particular controller.
And that thing is
responsible for looking
at the authorization header
and saying, you don't match,
or, you do match, and I'll let
you go a little bit further.
If you fail, you get a 401.
You do not go any further.
And that works
together with an object
called an authentication server,
which implements OAuth 2.
And then you provide
the persistence
for what the OAuth server wants.
So it'll say, hey, I want
you to store a token.
You store it in
Postgres or whatever
database you're working with.
So the way that these
routes are set up,
this concept of just sort
of chaining things together,
we want that metaphor
to make sense in the way
that you actually
write the code.
So you look at other
frameworks, some
of those controllers, those
things that handle things,
they kind of have to know
where they are in that.
They have to explicitly
say, hey, now
you can go onto the next one.
That type of behavior is sort
of handled at a higher level.
You're just returning
requests and response objects.
If you want to go
forward, return a request.
If you want to complete the
request and respond to it,
you return a response.
And this is the thing
that forms that stream.
So we set up a router.
We can pipe it to an Authorizer.
That's that thing that
checks for authentication.
And then we can generate
a new controller.
Now, there's a little subtle
difference here between pipe
and generate.
The idea is this.
When you have HTTP controller,
when a request comes in,
it has properties
that represent things
in that particular request.
It has that actual reference to
the request that's coming in.
If it decodes an
HTTP body, it's going
to have that body as a property.
And so when you're working in
an asynchronous environment,
this particular controller
could get halfway
through processing requests.
And then a new
request could come in,
and it would trump
those properties.
And that would be bad.
So generate means
for every request,
create a new
instance of this guy.
Pipe, because you
don't have to-- it's
just a pass-through, right?
The Authorizer does
not keep any state
about the request
it's processing.
So pipe versus generate--
small little nuance.
The different strategies
for these Authorizers--
so if you're familiar with
OAuth 2 specification,
you have a resource owner.
You have authorization code.
You have client.
The default is resource owner,
because most of your routes
will have that.
The ability to change
the strategy to something
like the application level,
client ID, client secret pair,
is done right here.
And so the idea is you
can come into one place
and kind of see the
entire structure
and flow of your application.
But all that code is
actually compartmentalized
and allows for a better
structure of your application.
The really great
part about this,
though, is because
of this structure,
you can actually spawn
that entire stream
onto multiple isolates.
And so this allows for
a lot of great things.
So you don't have to
do anything special.
You just set up
your requestSync,
and you say, here are my routes,
and here are my resources.
And there's this thing
called an application that
sort of manages
and supervises all
of these different isolates.
And it's responsible,
more or less,
for being able to round
robin deliver requests
into each one of these isolates.
You get multi-threading, right?
And each set, or each
isolate and its requestSync,
will have its own
set of resources,
like a database connection.
You don't necessarily
have to do it that way.
But when you think about
a typical application,
you probably have a pool
of database connections.
And as you're doing things
sort of concurrently,
you go and ask that pool,
hey, let me use your database
connection for a second.
I've made that request.
Now I'm done.
Here's the connection so
someone else can use it.
With this process, you don't
have to think about that.
Because each one of these guys
has their own set of resources.
And because of the way
that isolates work,
you can't really
get in a situation
where you create race
conditions between the two.
And opting into that
behavior, you just
specify when you
start the application.
So you have that requestSync.
That's the type parameter
for an application.
When you start the
application, you just say,
I want three of those things.
And the other great part
about that is it kind of
forces you into this model of
writing a stateless web server.
And so you already know that
once you've done it once
on one machine, it's
technically kind of distributed
across a number of threads
in that one machine.
So when you scale it out
to multiple machines,
you put it behind
a load balancer.
That stuff's just going to work.
You've already kind of
tested that behavior.
So that's the request
handling stuff.
There isn't really
anything-- other
than isolate stuff,
which is pretty neat.
It should be pretty
typical stuff.
Having an ORM is
another portion of this.
There are really
three major portions
that I'll touch on today and a
few accoutrements at the end.
And we're in Europe.
I probably pronounced
that wrong.
I don't know.
So the ORM here-- the way
you work with the database
is you create query objects.
And then you specify
the type of the object
that you're working with.
And then you execute
an operation on it.
And the great part about
Dart here is async await.
I'll be honest.
That was the deciding factor
for all of this stuff.
Having callbacks is
not exactly fun for me.
So this would, in
this particular case,
fetch every article
from a database.
So there is a corresponding
article table somewhere,
and it's got columns.
And we're pulling in
instances-- every single one,
in this case-- of
those articles.
The great part about
this is the things
that represent database rows
in our Aqueduct applications,
we don't have to do anything
special to serialize or encode
them, as I was saying
a little bit earlier.
I can pass them as the body
argument to a response,
and it knows how
to serialize them.
And then the HTTP
controller will actually
make the decision about
the encoding-- so JSON,
for example.
Now, you typically don't want
to fetch an entire table.
I don't think that
happens all that often.
Typically you want to have
some sort of WHERE clause.
And so this is the thing
I'm most excited about.
The idea is this.
When you create a
query object, there's
a property called matchOn.
I was trying to make this
sound like a sentence,
like, matchOn the
category where equal to.
It only really reads
like a sentence
if you were born
in a household that
spoke SQL-- not my household.
But the idea is this.
MatchOn has the
same properties--
it's an interface to the same
type that you're querying.
Now, there's some
special behavior
that goes on underneath the hood
to make this kind of all work.
But the idea is that now we
get the Analyzer and code
completion to help
us build our queries.
We don't really have to think
about, what do I name this?
And especially for
refactoring-- if you refactor
to rename something, and you
have extremely tight data,
you end up in a pretty
crappy situation.
This allows us to build
queries in a way that's
very similar to the way
that we do Dart tests.
Dart tests-- we use the
Hamcrest matchers style.
And so we have the same
concept of matchers
that we can apply to each
one of these properties.
So what we're
saying here is, hey,
I'm going to go
fetch some articles.
But I only want
the articles that
have a category that's equal to
whatever I got passed in here.
And I go to fetch them.
I get the subset of articles.
And I return them.
Now, you can match on
a number of properties.
It logically ANDs them together.
And there's also a
number of matchers.
And the matchers will
be appropriately--
you can pass in a date,
time, a number, a string.
The underlying mechanism
that takes care of this
is going to tell you
when you screwed up.
Unfortunately, it can't
do that at compile time.
But the idea is that you can
build most queries out of this.
And there's a manhole as well.
If you can't build a query
that you want to build,
you can drop down and just write
the WHERE clause by itself.
Or you could drop down and
just write SQL by itself.
So it's not preventing
you from getting deeper.
But the idea is it's
there to do the things
that you want to do in a
much more productive way.
With queries, you can insert,
update, delete, fetch,
all those sorts of things.
So this would be an example
of me wanting to update
one of these articles.
So when I'm building
a query for update,
not only do I still
get my matchOn--
and that's the
thing that's going
to specify which row
I'm going to update,
or number of rows that
I'm going to update.
There's also a values
object that a query has.
And again, it has
the same properties
that this article object has.
And so that's going to allow
me to configure that thing.
The great part about
that, of course,
is that the article object,
or any of these objects
that we use to
represent database rows,
have this readMap method.
And that's going to bring in,
from the request body that's
been decoded for
you, those values.
And it's going to validate them.
It's going to validate keys.
So you send a key that's not
appropriate, it'll throw a 400
for you.
It's going to validate
the types of those values
and just kind of make sure
you have the right data.
Now, one thing you'll
probably notice
is that I've really not
done any error handling.
And for that reason, you
might think I'm full of crap.
But the idea is when a query
has a failure-- so first of all,
if this article, if
this fails, if there's
a reason for this not to
validate, we're going to get
bumped out.
We're going to get
a 400 responded to.
With queries, there's plenty
of things that can go on.
I could not get a
connection to the database.
I could have written a really
weird query that doesn't work.
The user could have
given me something weird.
It could have a unique
constraint violation.
All those things are baked
into the request control.
Well, they're not really baked.
They're decoupled enough, right?
But when a query runs into
one of those situations,
it throws an exception.
And the request
controller knows how
to interpret that exception.
And so if this article, let's
say that for whatever reason,
update date is unique.
And that update date is
already in the database
for another row.
I'm going to get a unique
constraint violation exception
from when I execute this query.
The request controller layer is
going to look at that and say,
that's a 409.
And it's going to respond
409 to the requesting client.
In order to get all
that lovely behavior
about being able to model
a database in your Dart
application, it's really
a two component thing.
The first is something we
call a persistent type.
And the persistent type is
going to be a plain Dart class.
And that plain
Dart class is going
to have all the columns
that are on that table.
And the name of
that table is going
to be the name of this class.
And there's a number
of things that you
can set up-- indexing and
nullability and et cetera, et
cetera.
To get all the fun behavior
that I've discussed,
there's this concept
of a managed object.
If you're coming
from iOS, you've
seen a managed object
before, because I ripped off
the entire core data
stack to do this.
It's just a really good stack.
And so the idea is
that we kind of wrap
this thing in a managed object.
And I'm not going to get into
the specific details of how
that works.
But that's the thing
responsible for translating
between the database and
serializing and de-serializing
data.
We can also set
up relationships.
So if I have two objects,
one that contains the other--
this author, for example, has
a managed set of articles.
Managed set is, again, just like
a set, except for it's managed
like a managed object is.
On the other side of
that, I have to set up
an inverse relationship.
So what's going to happen here
is in this persistent type,
this resolves to
rows in a database.
And this, on the other
side of the relationship,
resolves to a
foreign key column.
And it will use the
idiomatic naming conventions
of the underlying database.
So this actually ends
up being author_ID,
because the primary
key of this guy is ID.
When I have a
relationship set up,
I can fetch an object
and its sub-objects.
So I can do a JOIN.
And that's really great,
because I use the matchOn
property again, and I say,
hey, I want to include these.
By default, you're not going
to grab an entire object
tree, right?
So you can choose
to opt into that.
When you do opt into
it, you can additionally
specify extra constraints
in the WHERE clause.
So I can say, listen, I
want this author's articles.
I want the author himself,
and then I want the articles.
But I only want the articles
that are written about rocks.
Another great thing--
database migrations.
So clearly, as you
build an application,
you've already defined your
data model in your application
by defining all these things.
I ripped this off from .NET.
Let me just clarify--
I'm not that smart.
I just ripped all
this stuff off.
But it's in Dart,
so it's better.
So the great thing about this
is you get a migration file.
You have a number of
migration files over time.
And you can execute
those migration files.
The other great thing
about that-- I'm not even
going to get into
this, because you
don't need to worry about it.
Oh, son of a-- all
right, there we go.
Because Aqueduct will
actually do this for you.
It will generate
your migration files
by reflecting on
your data model.
And so when you make
a change, you're
going to get that change
into the migration file.
There's things that
you can't 100% resolve.
What is a rename?
Is it a delete and
add, or is it a rename?
So it gives you an opportunity
to go in and modify
those files.
Once you've modified
them, you run validate.
And it'll tell you every single
thing that you did wrong.
And once you're cool
with it, you run upgrade,
and that's actually going to run
those actions in a transaction
against that database.
OK, I have three minutes, so
I'm going to go real fast.
Testing-- code that isn't
tested doesn't work, just one
of those things.
We try to have an ability to put
things in a test harness that
makes sense.
When you use the template
to create a new project,
this code's all written for you.
There's no mocking, OK?
The idea is this.
I don't trust mocks.
Because it's more code that I
wrote, and it's probably wrong.
So it actually
starts a web server.
It connects to a database.
It creates temporary
versions of your tables.
Those only exist for as long
as the connection is alive.
And then you can run your tests.
And we don't really care about
this because, again, that's
lower level.
Once you have that thing
running-- by the way,
this takes milliseconds.
Your tests are just,
hey, I want to go
make an authenticated
request for this end point.
It's a GET.
And when I get it back, there's
some additional matchers
to complement the test
framework that already exists
to match against the responses.
So here, you're saying,
listen, it needs to be at 200.
And this is going
to match the body.
The body gets decoded
according to its content type.
And then you can specify a
map or list and all kinds
of matchers to ensure that
the object that you got back
is accurate.
Make sense?
And there's that word again.
I like it-- "accoutrement."
Big thing-- it's a very
well-documented framework.
Because if it's not
well-documented,
you're not going to use it.
Documentation is up
on pub-- thank you
for doing that-- or Dart Docs.
The whole API is sort
of named consistently.
So the idea should be that if
you're dealing with queries--
if you type in
"query," you're going
to find all the things that
are related to queries, right?
You don't want to
make any surprises.
Classes need to be clean.
There's manholes, as I
was talking about before.
You can use bits and
pieces of this thing.
You can just use the ORM.
You can just use the
request controller stuff.
You could use bits and pieces
of the authentication mechanism
if you want to.
Customizable-- comes with
JSON and form-urlencoded,
because we have to
support the OAuth spec.
So if you want to add
protobufs or XML or anything
like that, these top-level
objects-- or these classes,
excuse me, stack
methods-- you can
add closures that are
responsible for serializing and
de-serialized data.
Or encoding and decoding--
they're different things.
Greatest part, though, I feel
like, especially when we're
working on a big team,
is it automatically
generates an open API
specification from your code.
There's things that you can
do to improve it-- thank you.
Somebody appreciates that.
There's things you can
do to improve and add
more information to that.
But just by default,
you're going
to get a lot of
information by just running
one script to get all of this.
And that's great.
Put in your build tools,
goes out to your entire team,
and no one gets to say, well,
when did you change this field?
More information is
available on our website.
These slides, kind of,
are up on SlideShare.
I changed all of
them last night.
But the gist is there.
And that's it for me.
[APPLAUSE]